trio structured concurrency for python
before we talk about concurrency and
trio and all of that stuff
uh let's go into a little bit of history
back at the dawn of time when dinosaurs
roamed the earth
and i was very very young there was a
control flow
mechanism called go to and
go to was the way you
went from one place to another in your
software
here is a language called basic
it's the first programming language i
ever used
and it is uh it's not widely used today
it was very popular in the uh
70s and early 80s
and here is a basic program it's a very
simple straightforward basic program
it just counts from 1 to 10 and prints
out a line with each of those numbers
on it and then it prints all done when
it's finished
and to prove to you that it works here
is
the output i apologize for the
quality of the commodore 64 screen it is
an
old cathode ray tube and um
downscaling it on the slides doesn't
seem to work all that well
but you can you can see and if you want
to you can make sure that the program
that's running is in fact the one that i
have
nicely syntax highlighted above
so the way this works is that
on line 40 you check
if your loop variable i is less than or
equal to 10
you go to line 20 but there's no
other than the number next to the go to
there's no actual link so you
the only time you know that line 20 is
a place that your program can jump to is
when you get to line 40 and read to go
to
but this is a very simple program it's
fairly straightforward it's only five
lines long
so let's look at a more complicated one
this is a program it has three go-to's
in it
so it's not actually all that complex by
programming control flow standards
but um i'd be willing to bet
that very few people in here can
actually
read and understand that program without
drawing diagrams or stepping through it
or executing it
or whatever i know that i certainly
can't and i'm the person who wrote this
program
what it does as you can tell by the
input prompts at the top is it prints
out
some number of primes so let's run it
with printing out the first 10 primes
and there you go if somebody wants to
confirm that those are in fact
prime numbers
now
this program has three go-to's in it
they all jump to different places
and it's it's a mess
it's a very simple algorithm it
basically has
uh three nested loops in it but
nobody's going to follow that easily
um fortunately we were rescued from goto
by the
invention of structured programming
which
i'm a little young to have lived through
that it happened
around the time i was busy learning what
buttons on a keyboard did and
in modern languages we don't use go to
we use
for and while and
if and we have nice blocks python has
particularly
nicely visible blocks so the first
program i wrote and
i had in basic there that printed out 10
lines here's the equivalent in python
much easier to follow no go to's you can
tell
that the the indented print is the thing
that happens
uh in the loop and the all that happens
at the end
and you can tell immediately where the
but that repeats starts and ends
and here is the equivalent of the prime
numbers
uh program it's still complicated it's
not that easy to follow
but at least you can tell where the
loops are and you know that the stuff at
the beginning
before the while is stuff that
isn't uh going to repeat and the stuff
inside the wild is the outer loop and
then there's a
an inner loop and etc etc
as an aside one of my favorite little
bits about this program
is the else block on the end of a four
you can do that with while loops as well
and anything in that else block
runs after the loop but only if you
don't break out of the loop
so that runs for prime numbers because
we haven't
broken out of the loop it doesn't run if
you break out of the loop so
it's a it's a neat way of knowing
whether your for loop
ended successfully or if it broke
um else is a really really horrible
word to use there though um which is
probably why
this uh construct isn't used more often
um uh if anyone wants i can
switch from sharing the presentation to
sharing
a terminal window and run these programs
to prove that they are actually the
equivalent
but we can maybe do that later because
switching the presentation stuff is a
bit tedious and annoying
so getting rid of goto
didn't just give us um nice execution
flow that humans can reason about
it did a whole lot more than that
um it let us have call stacks and local
variables
in our functions and the reason for that
is that go to doesn't just jump around
inside a function
it can jump to anywhere in the code so
you can jump from the middle of one
function to the middle of a completely
different function
and if you can do that then you can't
reliably
you can't rely on local variables
because they may not have been set
you've got all the ones from the
previous function instead of the new
function
uh you your call stack doesn't make
sense anymore because you're now in a
function that was never called
so getting rid of goto lets you have
these things
you can have exceptions and nice error
handling because now you've got call
stacks you can
unwind them you can jump to your uh
caller you can you can wrap a
try except around some nested piece of
code and
catch any error that handles that
happens inside it
and something that python does
particularly well
is that you can have context managers
and with blocks
so with open file name
as file you can open a file for the
duration of a block
and then no matter how you leave that
block whether it's
by reaching the end of it or raising an
exception or
anything else you'll get you'll be
guaranteed that when
your program flow leaves that block
the file will be closed and you can do
this with anything
so that's all all these wonderful things
you can get
just by not having go to anymore
so that's some history and
uh the first the part of this uh
the name of this talk is uh concurrency
we've talked about structured
in the history lesson and now let's talk
about concurrency
so what is concurrency here are some
words that
spring to mind when somebody mentions
concurrency i can throw in a few more
uh race conditions
um philosophers with strange habits in
cutlery
et cetera et cetera all of these things
are associated with
concurrency but they're not actually
what concurrency is
so at its core concurrency is having
multiple
independent flows of execution so
instead of having
one flow of execution through your
program
where you go from line 10 to line 20 to
line 30 to line 40 and then jumping back
to line 20 etc etc etc
you can have multiple of those happening
maybe at the same time maybe
switching between them may be
interleaved
the ordering of those things doesn't
matter because they're independent
they can happen in any order
and the thing that makes it interesting
and difficult is having communication
between those flows of execution
because if they don't talk to each other
or know about each other they may as
well be
different programs running on different
computers
in different cities doing different
things that
don't know or care about each other at
all technically
my program running and your program
running
are concurrent systems but they're
completely disconnected from each other
so
it doesn't matter when you've got
communication it gets interesting
and useful and also difficult
so concurrency has its own go-to which
we use
a lot i'm going to call it spawn
different languages call it different
things
the one the name that's closest to go to
is the language go which
calls its spawn primitive go
but having go and go to and goes a very
common word so
it's confusing to talk about so i'll
stick with spawn
this is erlang which is a language from
the 80s
so about 10 15 maybe 20 years after
basic whether to go to
don't worry too much about the syntax
you're not expected to
read and understand this program at a
glance
but there are two main parts to this
program
the first bit which is now highlighted
is a
recursive function which um
every time through the loop it prints
out a message and
then sleeps for 200 milliseconds and
then
prints out the next message it counts
downwards rather than upwards
like the basic program did just because
it's
easier to do that with recursion and
little less code
adding a few lines i could make it print
forwards instead but that's just extra
complexity
and then the thing that makes it
concurrent is in the main
uh function here we
spawn at once with task one is the
message
and then we spawn it the second time
with task two as the message
and then we just wait for them to finish
so i will actually uh
switch the presentation thing and
run this um if i can find the right
window
there it is
so here is that erling program running
and maybe it's running a little
fast uh let me just like that
instead of 200 milliseconds let's make
it
a thousand and let's make that sleep for
six seconds
so there we have it both tasks running
counting down
simultaneously and at the end
we finish async io which is the standard
library
concurrency async framework for python
uh
calls it create task instead of spawn
so here's a the previous the equivalent
of the
erlang program written using async io
we have the function that prints the
message
every 200 milliseconds
uh sleeping in between
and we have the main function which
spawns two tasks
um and runs them concurrently
but it doesn't just spawn the
the two tasks it uh oh hey i can see my
mouse cursor here it first
runs the function once kind of
synchronously so waits for that to
finish
and then it spawns two tasks in parallel
so
these two things will happen at the same
time but only after
this one is finished
um but the important thing here is that
a task is just an object that can be
passed around
and there's no link between the place
the task is
created and where it starts running and
where you wait for it so
you can have things that get lost and go
missing
and tasks that get orphaned
so here is um
one of the big problems with async
programming in python especially
but in pretty much any async system
where do errors go so we have
a an asynchronous function that
waits for a little bit and then throws
an exception and we call it in three
different ways
so the first one we call create task we
assign it to a variable and then we just
never wait for it
so the error from this task
just nothing ever catches it
there's nowhere else in the program for
it to go because we never wait for it to
finish
so the error for this one will get lost
um what python does is
when the task object gets garbage
collected
which can happen at some arbitrary time
in the future
um we'll get a runtime error that gets
logged
and if you're not looking at your logs
well you don't know
it's not even an error it's a warning we
just don't know what happens with it
the second one um we create a task
and we do await on it but only later
so it raises its error
the error just sits there waiting in the
task object and then when we await it
right at the end of the program then we
get the error
and then it gets raised but again
there's no link between where the task
is created and where we wait for it
so if we create this task in some
deeply nested complicated piece of code
none of that shows up in the stack trace
the only thing that shows up in the
stack
trace is the function that uh raised the
error
and the main which uh
called the await it's a little more
complicated than that but basically
stack traces are very confusing
and often have the wrong things in them
when you're dealing with async
exceptions
and the only one that actually makes any
sense is
this one where we create the task and
immediately
await it but if we're going to do that
we may as well not create the task at
all we may as well just
um await rey's error
because we're not doing anything uh
concurrently there we're just running
uh sequentially running stuff in another
task so this is one of the big problems
not the only problem with
async stuff but one of the big ones
that's kind of equivalent to
some of the problems we saw with go to
where you can't do proper error handling
and there's no way to know
where your control flow came to at any
point in the code
um so this brings us to
structured concurrency which i'm not
going to have an example here because
that's what the next section of the talk
is for
but the core idea in structured
concurrency is that any task that's
spawned
in a block of code must finish in that
same block of code
so there's no way to spawn a task and
then move on to do something else
and your program's somewhere completely
hidden away or in a completely different
part of the program when your
errors happen or when your tasks finish
so this is one idea it's a very simple
idea but it's very powerful it's the
same
kind of idea that you get from go to
uh not being able to jump from the
middle of one function to the middle of
another function
the advantages of structured concurrency
as we'll see
is first you get execution flow that
humans can reason about
the same as with go to we can now see
what our code is doing we know where all
the
concurrent tasks are happening
we can have nested contexts and task
local states so that's
kind of like having a call stack and
local variables
only with concurrency so i can spawn a
task and then that task can spawn its
own tasks
and the the
myspawn task will wait until its tasks
are all finished before it finishes
and everything is nicely ordered and
structured
and there is always somewhere for errors
to go
and we always know what states are our
program is in
which brings us to well-defined
cancellation and error handling
so if you have if one of your subtasks
uh raises an exception which isn't
caught well that bubbles up to the
the block that spawned it and then
everything inside that block gets
cancelled
um because that's what happens if you
get an error
your your block stops and then you'll
you get that exception raised um
more more detail on that in a bit
but most importantly no often tasks or
missing results
so you never have code that just
goes on forever and everything's lost
track of it and nobody knows what it's
doing
and it could be doing anything
so the third part of the the title
uh of this talk is trio which is
what we'll be using which trio is built
on the ideas of structured concurrency
so the best way to learn about trio is
to read the documentation
so i think we're done here you can all
go off and read the documentation
and everything will be great
the docs are actually excellent so you
could just go and do that that's what i
did
but since we still have a few minutes
left of this talk um i'll i will
actually
talk about trio some more
so brief um intro to async
programming you've got async code that
can call sync code
um but don't call anything that blocks
and sync code can't call async code
sync and async sound way too similar
when i'm saying them
but anyway synchronous code can't call
async code
uh unless you're writing a framework
like trio or async io and then there's
some special mechanisms
to make that work
so here are some ways you can get async
code wrong
the first is to try and await something
in a sync
function uh and that you'll know
immediately because the compiler gives
you a syntax error
you're not going to miss that in your
code
the other thing you can get wrong is to
forget to await
an async code
so here we have we're
calling an async function but we're not
using a weight
and thus you get a runtime warning
logged and you
you don't get well what you actually get
printed there
is the representation of a co-routine
object
um that's
that's kind of an implementation detail
and this is unfortunately a symptom
of the concurrency perimeter in python
is basically spawn and
we're building the structure on top of
spawn so it's the same
as building your for loops and while
loops and if blocks and whatever
on top of co2 if if goto is still there
under the hood while you can get some of
the benefits
of not having go-to you can't get all of
them you can't trust that there won't be
some code somewhere
that users go to and breaks everything
but trio does provide some tools for
debugging stuff
i'm not going to talk about
trio.abc.instrument
anymore in this talk but it is
incredibly useful and the docs explain
how to use it
so if you find yourself with code that
seems to be doing weird stuff it might
be a good starting point for debugging
so how does trio actually do the
structured
concurrency the main thing here
is it's called the nursery so instead of
having
the equivalent of async io.createtask
which you can call anywhere
the only way to create a background task
is to use a nursery so this code
as before we have our task function that
just
prints a message n times
and in our main function here instead of
using
create task we use nursery.start soon
and we have this um
async block with the nursery
so async with open nursery as nursery
and what that does is um
any tasks started by this nursery
uh will cause the the block
to to block basically the block doesn't
end until all the subtasks are finished
so you'll notice we never await anything
in this block
but both tasks uh
well task one will print its four lines
task two will print its two lines
uh both of them will finish before we
leave this block and get to the
all then um
and to answer bruce's uh
question because this is a good time for
it
um if you want to have uh separate uh
sort of overlapping lifespans for
uh tasks the way you can get that is a
nursery is an object
you can pass a nursery into a subtask
so if you want to have a task that's
allowed to create
sort of sibling tasks you can pass the
nursery to that task and it can create
tasks that outlive itself
but they don't outlive the nursery
there it's explicit you can't do that
without explicitly passing the nursery
to your
subtask so there's a mechanism
for it but it your life your lifetime of
your
your tasks is still limited you can't
outlive the parent it's just you can
you can pass the parents around and
create uh
you can have your subtasks create sort
of siblings instead of their own
children
um i don't have an example for that
though
but it's straightforward enough to to
figure out if you play with it
um a really nice consequence of this
is timeouts if anyone has ever tried to
have a timeout on an http request
you will understand the pain there are
multiple different kinds of timeouts are
you talking about
a connection timeout
so you'll stop trying if you haven't
made a network connection
within some amount of time but once the
connection's made
well the the server can take three hours
to
send your response and
you just have to sit and wait or maybe
you have
a timeout on
the server or the amount of time between
data being received it gets really
complicated
and what if you want to run three uh
make three requests
sequentially and have a timer for all of
them
well you have to now figure out how long
the first
request took and subtract that from your
timeout etc
really really uh nasty with
trio you use the
async block so you've got um
the first thing uh first bit of code
here is
trio dot move on after with three
seconds
so the entire body of that block
will um take at most
three seconds so here we've got four
seconds worth of stuff
um we
uh go to sleep we wait a little bit
we print still sleeping we wait a little
bit and then we
wake up on our own after three seconds
that block will be cancelled um and
because it says move on after
we don't care about that we we don't
care that it didn't finish
we just care that it doesn't take too
long
so no exception will be raised we'll
just move on
if i put my focus on the correct place i
can
move on the next one is
fail after which is the same as move on
except
instead of just moving on it actually
fails
so we this example also has a nursery
because the nursery is inside the
the timeout block um the
the timeout applies to all the subtasks
and the body of the nursery
and because we use fail we get an
exception
if we take too long so this simplifies
timeouts immensely
all you need to worry about is how long
do i want this block of code to take
at most and
then you can do whatever you like inside
that and be guaranteed that
your your entire block won't take longer
than that
um and i mentioned uh
things being cancelled so the timeout is
kind of a special case of
um errors and cancellation
so cancellation is
basically killing a task it's a little
more complicated than that under the
hood
there are checkpoints where
uh trio as a framework gets to
um past bits of code
well gets to raise exceptions and stuff
basically anytime you call a function in
the trio namespace
or an async function in the trio
namespace there's a checkpoint inside
there where things can be cancelled
if you're just writing code that uses
trio all you need to worry about
is as long as you're not cpu bound and
as long as you're
awaiting something in the trio name
space somewhere in your call chain
um your stuff can be cancelled
but
anytime you've got an exception in any
of your
subtasks an exception uh
that exception sort of bubbles up and
whenever it gets to a nursery
all tasks inside that nursery are also
cancelled
um and then you can catch exceptions
as normal around the
nursery trio does also
handle the case where multiple tasks
raise
exceptions simultaneously
which is also a little more complicated
than wilford on one slide but the docs
do a really good job of
explaining that and in general you don't
need to worry about that too much unless
you're doing multiple different things
concurrently in a nursery
and trio also comes with a whole lot of
other features
so it's got um
task local storage like thread local
storage
except for tasks it's got mechanisms for
communicating between
tasks so events and channels are the
main ways of
using communication but they're also
lower level things locks semaphores
etc etc um there if you need them
you can use asynchronous generators but
because
of the way they interact with the
low-level
sort of spawn level stuff in python
you have to be really careful with those
so it's probably best to avoid them
if you really need to unless you really
need them
and then be careful you can use threads
if you must
and that's actually the title of the
section of the documentation that
explained that uh
talks about them threads if you must
um you can have async file system
operations
which is really difficult to do because
kernels generally don't provide good
tools for them
uh trio cheats and basically just wraps
synchronous file system operations in
uh threads under the hood but it's a
good idea to use those
to avoid maybe blocking for 30 seconds
if you have a very busy disk or
something
you can have sub processes all the good
things
that any async framework
provides
so in conclusion uh what have we learned
so far firstly we've learned that goto
is bad
but hopefully we already knew this and
in fact if python is our language of
choice
uh we don't even get
go-to it's never been in the language
um just like go to spawn is bad no
matter how you spell it
and uh structured concurrency is great
hopefully i've given you enough of a
taste of it that you
you're interested in trying it out and
if so you should definitely use trio for
your next asic project
personal anecdote uh we have
a system that talks to let's encrypt
uh to manage certificates for a cluster
and that's built with twisted because we
built it like
uh five years ago and it worked
great until uh let's encrypt
retired their version one api and the
library we were using didn't support
version two and it was quicker and
easier
to learn trio and re-implement
the whole system in trio from scratch
than it was to try
and update the library to use
the slightly different two api
um and deploy a new version of the thing
we already had
so trio is great
and that's the end